if you were still living in Michigan and
you didn't have the looks to get you to
the modeling and the and then the
modeling to the acting and all this
stuff and let's say it just stopped at
bartending and construction what do you
honestly think if you could honestly say
hey this is probably what I would have
done my grandfather was a firefighter
and I've always thought about that
because what I love about firefighters
is they help people yeah you know maybe
that turned into the Clark thing I don't
know like when the cops show up you're
like ah but when the firefighters
show up they're they're there to help
you how funny is that that you would
have gone into a firefighting to help
people but instead you became an actor
playing a character that helps and prend
pretending to help but how many people
have told us how important this show was
to them or when when they saw it with
their dad and and their dad's no longer
with them but it was a memory it was
like or they got him through a tough
time